sí no
caramba nadie más de corazón que para
darle cuerpo vaciló
vivimos en la era espacial desde octubre
de 1957 cuando la urss puso en órbita al
sputnik 1 el primer satélite artificial
hecho por la humanidad cuatro años
después
en abril de 1961 yuri gagarín de una
órbita completa a nuestro planeta en la
cápsula espacial vostok de la urss
en ese entonces no se pudo ver su hazaña
por televisión
porque aún no existía una red de
televisión satelital
sólo ocho años después en julio del 69
la misión apolo 11 logró que en el
austro pisara la luna y disfrutará de la
primera caminata por nuestro satélite
natural su hazaña sí fue televisada en
vivo
a todo el mundo y muchísimas familias en
todo el mundo pudieron disfrutar y ver
como él caminaba por la luna las
misiones apolo requirieron la
participación de 400 mil personas de
2000 organizaciones diferentes
aprender a coordinar este tipo de
trabajo tan complejo requirió un salto
en las capacidades organizacionales que
se tenían en la época esta nueva
capacidad incorporándose a todo tipo de
organizaciones y empresas permitiéndoles
a su vez realizar proyectos cada vez más
complejos la actividad espacial ha sido
siempre uno de los motores principales
del cambio tecnológico
este efecto multiplicador que se observó
en los eeuu desarrollando un cambio
tecnológico económico y social a partir
de las misiones espaciales en el
desarrollo espacial se volvió a observar
luego en europa en japón y en todos los
países que emprendieron la difícil tarea
de desarrollarse espacialmente y hoy lo
estamos viendo en la argentina con
nuevas capacidades y empresas que han
surgido alrededor del esfuerzo estatal
del desarrollo espacial del país
porque se da esto
simplemente porque el espacio es más
difícil es más duro no realizamos las
cosas como estamos acostumbrado en la
tierra no hay gravedad
no hay atmósfera el ambiente es hostil
la atmósfera no nos protege de la
radiación solar
hasta el movimiento de diferente no se
controla igual entonces al ser todo tan
difícil y hostil
requiere mucha más capacidad y esfuerzos
para lograr los objetivos de hecho es
por esto que en el espacio siempre hubo
más robots que personas esto ha generado
una necesidad de que estos robots sean
cada vez más autónomos y capaces y esto
genera una presión continua para el
desarrollo de estas capacidades que fue
clave por ejemplo para el desarrollo de
la robótica y del ente ejerce artificial
en tiempos cuando aún no eran rentables
la tecnología espacial hoy se ha tornado
omnipresente y ya no pensamos en que lo
utilizamos no nos percatamos de eso ni
de la dependencia que tenemos en ella
desde las comunicaciones a los sistemas
de navegación que pese a las múltiples
aplicaciones que parten de datos de
observación de las tierras del espacio
simplemente los utilizamos la lista de
cosas que podemos mirar hoy del espacio
es increíble
la deforestación inundaciones incendios
forestales la calidad del agua la
calidad del aire corrientes marinas
cenizas volcánicas y cada día se agrega
una nueva e incluso algunas que primero
no pensamos podrían estar relacionadas
con espacial como por ejemplo temas
relativos a la salud como la enfermedad
del dengue chagas
la mirada del espacio no tiene fronteras
nosotros podemos saber estas cosas no
sólo de nuestro país sino de cualquier
país en la tierra
el valor que esto tiene es fácil de
ejemplificar con un par de preguntas
cuánto vale conocer que siembra en otros
países
cuánto vale saber cómo va la cosecha en
esos países para nosotros
cuánto vale saber que vamos a tener una
enfermedad como el dengue llegando a la
argentina
la información espacial la tecnología
espacial presenta un gran reto para
todos nosotros para todos los países
organizaciones y empresas y aquellos que
abracen este cambio van a tener muchas
oportunidades y ventajas y los que no
desventajas
no me refiero sólo a empresas sare
espaciales sino a todo tipo de empresas
como comunes de actividad como un
digamos como inmobiliarias productores
agrícolas aseguradoras que hoy ya
utilizan este tipo de información las
investigaciones desarrolladas en
instituto woolrich han logrado concretar
aplicaciones de un alto valor económico
y social como por ejemplo la predicción
de la dinámica de cientos forestales
como índices de sequía que son
utilizables por las aseguradoras como
mapas de riesgo de enfermedades como el
dengue y chagas en este último caso la
argentina lidera el desarrollo de estas
aplicaciones a nivel mundial y no es tan
común que estemos
liderando temas científicos si quiere
subrayar por estos logros científicos y
por la capacidad mostrada por la
argentina
en el desarrollo a través de la conade
de varias misiones espaciales algunas de
ellas con nasa también por el desarrollo
de las dos satélites con estacionarios
de arsat y por varios emprendimientos
recientes incluso algunos privados y
también por olores de la comunidad
científica y por la cooperación que
tenemos internacional permanente es que
argentina se está posicionando como uno
de los principales líderes en la parte
espacial en latinoamérica no es posible
ignorar los cambios que la era espacial
produce las consecuencias se sentirán
cada día más la era espacial recién
comienza lo maria tendrá robots y
sistemas cada día más inteligentes cada
día más hábiles y estos sistemas se
utilizarán para observar para explorar
ver lo que globalmente sucede casi
instantáneamente y para incluso analizar
tomar decisiones y actuar después de
haber tenido una muy buena experiencia
con un emprendimiento tecnológico de
joven de haber participado en con aire
de punta a punta en muchas misiones
espaciales de haber liderado proyectos
tecnológicos con éxito de haber
transferido conocimientos a muchas
personas de haber contribuido desde mi
rol en el estado al desarrollo de
empresas
tecnológicas en el país de haber
liderado las operaciones de la misión
sac-d/aquarius de nasa y conae
quisiera dejarles este mensaje
hoy es más imprescindible que nunca
vivir en este futuro en lo personal
siempre viví un poco en el futuro viendo
venir con cierta antelación algunas de
las cosas que luego se tornaron realidad
algunas buenas y otras malas pero nunca
se trató de clarividencia o de una
película fantasiosa del futuro imaginar
que cualquier cosa será el futuro
siempre la clave está en saber que va a
ser parte de este futuro y si esta
capacidad se puede adquirir y gracias al
estudio a la investigación a la
experimentación a la experiencia
al espíritu crítico
producto de la aventura espacial en la
que nos encontramos
hoy cada día se creó en una oportunidad
y está en cada uno de nosotros
conectarse y aprovecharla acrecentando
nuestras capacidades como individuos
posicionando nuestros emprendimientos
mejorando nuestras ciudades y nuestro
país
los espejos
[Música]